[Music]
let it go Kim because he's stating the
obvious Wendy Williams is jumping into
the unexpected a feud of brewing between
Kim Zolciak Biermann and Marlon Wayans
it's drama it's inevitable
here's the back story on Sunday Bravo
released a first look at part two of The
Real Housewives of Atlanta season 10
reunion featuring Kim Marlon posted a
screen grab from that sneak peek to
Instagram captioning it no we are not in
production on white chicks to the
somebody's what you walking on in there
son Kim it then called Marlon out in the
comments writing was always a super big
fan of yours and my kids loved you this
hurts but I guess it's all for laughs
it's a tough room you know there's a
tough room things then escalated when
Marlon and Kim were each caught by
paparazzi and talked about it more Tim
telling cameras she thought it was
distasteful to make fun of a woman's
looks in the time of me too and on
Tuesday Wendy gave her take on all of
that during hot topics what does this
have to do with me to move in okay
you're a housewife and he's a comedian
and there was a funny screengrab what
are you saying to me to move it what
does that mean you can't say anything
about women because the me2 movement you
understand what I'm saying
[Music]
[Applause]